can qualcomm also let's take a brief
step away from mobile and take on intel
and apple
and other such companies in the laptop
and desktop space so
the nature of what a computer is seems
to be changing it's like smartphones
like merging it's all being a smartphone
just with a bigger screen or something
like this so what does the future of
that look like
before i answer that question let me
just step back a little bit because and
i'm sure we can we can talk more about
those things but the
the reality is qualcomm is changing a
lot and we use i know we spend a lot of
time talking about 5g and smartphone and
snapdragon and i think that has been
what had defined qualcomm for many years
but the reality is even
consistent with that 5g conversation
which is a technology to connect
everything
qualcomm is also changing
our technology there was in many cases
design for phones and we said in the
beginning connectivity and processing
is going to virtually every industry and
as a result qualcomm
is really changing with it and expanding
to a number of different addressable
markets
some of those markets
is
is the pc as you talk about it
the the conversions of mobile and pc
and the reason i'm excited about this
because you see a lot of things
happening that bring this right front
and center when you think about the
future technology so
what we learn with the pandemic
is that the number one use case
of personal computers is communications
uh it is interesting when you think
about that that's the number one use
case on a pc today is communications
it's actually funny because in the
cellular industry actually i'll say let
me step back in the telecom industry
we've been chasing this killer
application of video telephony for
decades right i remember uh
back then in the wire line uh even
before the internet an ip i isdn you
remember those uh att desk phones with a
little screen and they said you can do
video telephony we don't watch that uh
in uh back to the future too then when
we started developing 3g and people said
what's the application for having data
to cell phone or video telephony then we
started doing 4g
and in the beginning people said well
why do you need all this broadband oh
vega telephony
but it took a pandemic to make video
telephony the killer application and
that's now the number one
uh use case on a pc so now think about
that for a second
personal computers now they're
technologies that people when they're
going to buy a pc they didn't care much
about it now they do camera
camera how good is the camera the audio
is that connected how good is the
connectivity do you have the latest and
greatest wi-fi and cellular
what's the battery life because you're
going to be working from anywhere
sometimes you know that sometimes you're
not
so all those things what's the
portability like so those things started
to change how we should think about the
pc but i won't stop there let me talk
about another trend
so
and all come as a result of what we saw
the pandemic
let's say that you are you're an
engineer in the computer aided design
you you have advanced
desktop
computer or workstation in your office
but you want to work from home someday
so you're not going to move that to your
home so what do you need to do you're
going to have to rely on that
you're going to run that on the cloud
and you're going to run under the cloud
you need high bandwidth because you
almost wanted the cloud to be
the same as your computer for that use
case that's the 5g on-demand computing
use case the us5g is always a link
between two computers
but then you know cios are saying well
my workforce is going home for certain
days i want all the data to be in the
cloud you look at for example microsoft
onedrive or the ability to collaborate
you need the bandwidth
so
that when you put all of those things
together you start thinking about what
is the next generation pc
and that's the opportunity for qualcomm
i'll just give an example
uh back in uh
mobile congress uh recently lenovo
they have a line of
of uh
enterprise laptops called the thinkpad
i'm sure you're familiar with it so they
announced the thinkpad based on
snapdragon
with 5g on
28 hours of battery life
so so that's next generation it's just a
nice screen with extremely high
nice screen and keyboard
uh and extremely high connectivity to
maybe an even more like a more powerful
machine in cloud something more the data
connecting to the data containing to
compute all that kind of stuff you have
the camera capabilities and let me go uh
one set more microsoft talking about
some of the features they're doing now
using
on windows 11 using snapdragon remember
we talked about a snapdragon has an ai
processor inside there so one of the
cool features microsoft's talking about
it is you can be on a teams call
and you can make sure your eyes are
looking at the camera
of the time well that's an interesting
so they can be talking you can do that
with ai yes that's really tricky to pull
off for example the reason i'm a huge
stickler for doing these in person these
conversations in person it's really
tough to get right but it's a worthy
challenge so that's where the metaverse
hopes to so like i just because you said
the importance of this telephony of
humans connecting teleporting themselves
getting that right is really difficult
because a lot of people hate zoom
meetings but that doesn't mean you can't
improve that experience and get rid of
the hate a lot of people hate talking to
their car too because the voice
the natural language processing is
terrible but when it's not it's a
beautiful thing so getting that right is
this is an opportunity this is an
opportunity think about it it starts
with the pc making
the pc giving you a better experience
for teams but then it goes right back
into
this trend of connecting physical and
digital spaces and all the work we're
doing with the metaverse and virtual
reality materiality in the future is why
not
call somebody or connect with somebody
with a hologram it's possible and also
to mention
some
increasing amount of intelligence in our
cars so semi-autonomous autonomous cars
and the interactivity between human and
and car which are for me things are
uh really exciting let me ask you a big
question so when when aliens again now
on the other side
right and humans destroy themselves
through nuclear war centuries from now
let's hope not let's hope not but in
case you know let's just hypothetical
thought experiment and they write a
history of humanity in the 21st century
uh
what would they remember qualcomm
in the 21st century as a company would
be a car company would it be like think
of all the crazy pivots that might
happen the next like 50 years
because because you're thinking you said
qualcomm enables all of these things
with 5g and they'll be probably other
g's it keeps increasing so basically
connectivity and computation
and everything becomes connected and
everything is capable of computation
might you be become a robotics and car
company
um i will argue we're already an
automotive
company today and but let me tell what i
what i would like qualcomm to be
remember and recognize for
i think everyone
that knows qualcomm immediately
you know connect us pun intended
to connectivity and wireless but the
reality is we're being actually the
company providing intelligence and and
processing to everything on the edge
everything outside the data center
that we're doing those billions of
devices that are going to be connected
and and that's kind of explained when we
talk about the connected intelligent
edge the beyond phones cars pcs and all
of those and the broader iot as we talk
about everything will be connected and
intelligent and that's what we want
qualcomm to be recognized for so by the
way for people who are not familiar
there's some technical jargon but people
use the word edge like edge computing
it's
by the way that's probably changing what
that even means but it's basically
everything that's not a giant thing
that's making a lot of noise in a
building somewhere so it's mobile
devices
and the mobile devices of all kinds of
well a refrigerator is not mobile but it
would be edge so it's it's like what's a
sandwich that kind of discussion
um
but basically edge computing
is is uh the edge of that expanding
space that you mentioned that qualcomm
is trying to
connect and enable with computation
here's a simple way to describe what the
edge is in edge computing is i think as
we think about the evolution of the data
center
you need to bring the computational
closer to where the device is
also when you put the computation
together with the connectivity at the
same time you're going to see a lot of
advancement of artificial intelligence
happening closer to or at the device
look it's a very i have a simple way to
describe it remember
in the beginning of this conversation we
talked about in the 4g era broadband and
mobile computing evolve side by side if
you're going to have broadband you might
as well have a computer in the palm of
your hand so we needed to invest in
those two technologies
in 5g
ai develops side by side you're
connected to the cloud 100 of the time
you have a high bandwidth and you have
now a smart and intelligent thing that
can make decision in real time
provide context information to the cloud
to make the models more accurate and as
well compare and contrast the cloud so
there's going to be an exponential
development ai happening with
all the edge devices the devices that
are outside the data center and
computation is going to go alongside
that and a great example that's the car
the car you know uh we haven't talked
much about the car but you know qualcomm
is now
you could argue with as much as an
automotive company as wireless company
working 26 global brands
and it's easy to see
if you look at our mobile heritage and
we talk about
form factors thermal
battery life you're not going to put a
server in the trunk of a car but you
need as much computational capabilities
and as we see qualcomm
providing you know as the car become a
connected computer on wheels we provide
the computational and all the sensors
for you to do assisted driving for the
new digital cockpit experience
connecting the car to the cloud and it's
all that's happening at the end
you